you're listening to the cat digital
network and now Tim Dylan is going to
have
[Music]
welcome to Tim Dylan's going to hell
everybody we are here on the back deck
again with my friend comedian very funny
Kevin tinkin hello thank you for being
here again having me
no problem again folks we're outside you
might hear a little you might hear a
helicopter the screech of Annie you'll
you might hear something like that but
you don't have to you don't have to get
on the DM and tell me about it unless
it's a positive [ __ ] comment unless
you're like this is so [ __ ] nice that
you're doing this outside yeah because
we got some ambient noise in the
background so I can fall asleep I
imagine most of you fall asleep
listening to the sound of my voice I
hope that that's that's all I get sober
yeah oh I wonder how many people are
listening to this show either sobering
up or relapsing yeah if yeah definitely
one of the two if you're going through a
police checkpoint you've had a few
drinks
yeah pod sober up yeah so you know but I
like doing them outside maybe it's
something about being in LA there's
something nice about being outside here
in New York City you know there's so
many [ __ ] people everywhere you can't
do anything outside without involving
the neighbor or you know somebody
hollering at you to get some bootlegs
yeah yeah somebody selling their their
mixtape oh yeah you know you're the guy
that comes up to the gas station and
goes hey I want to give you my CD and
then he goes ten bucks no I've never had
a gas station to me in New York they do
it in Times Square yeah but you know
what how much better off of those guys
and most people that we know oh yeah
there's no trying to sell something else
they're trying they figured out a
marketing strategy for their [ __ ] art
is direct to marketing I had I was a
tour guide in New York City on the
double-decker buses and we would get
people and then like a British woman
came up to me and she's like okay if a
man $60 in Central Park he sold me a CD
she's like oh they're really a hundred
thousand homeless
children in New York I'm like I don't
know maybe probably I don't know then
she goes like this she goes well that
man told me that if I bought his CD the
money goes to the homeless children
donation for the homeless children in
New York there's a hundred thousand
homeless I'm like I told him like ma'am
you know I don't did he have any like it
was just a guy yeah walked up to her
with a CD which by the way brilliant
move on his part instead of just being
like because what they do is if you've
ever in New York they give you the CD
for free they go like hey I'm and then
they go and buy and then they'll take it
back if you won't give the money yep
they put the CD in your hand and they go
hey by the way I'm a struggling artist
I'm try to get my music out there so all
these British people and and like people
from Norway come over - they've never
seen black people oh yeah so they're
excited yeah to get a CD from the black
and they want to act like you're cool
you know what I mean people don't get
mad at me it's not all white people
doing this one of the shots a lot of
white people slinging mixtapes in
Central Park or Times Square there's
just not it's fun you know what I mean
yeah yeah and I thought these mixtapes
are good it's not not a lot of white
kids doing it anybody by the way if you
see a white person doing this shoot them
like the cops you able to shoot white
people who are selling mixtape those
numbers up anyway right we gotta get
those those white kids getting shot
numbers up I mean I'm not a big guy on
cultural appropriation but I'll tell you
right now every now and then I see
something that make me sick a white kid
selling a mixtape will throw me into a
funk I'll be like that is not your
[ __ ] turf get the [ __ ] out of here but
it's the wrong area it's the wrong area
but you do see that you do you do see
that a lot in terms of like these
foreign people that want to be cool did
their hustling and then and then they
get this this this mixtape and then
they're like standing there and then a
lot of them will just give the money
because they don't know yeah you know
they don't know they're like I don't
want to you know see they're guilty oh
yeah you know some Scandinavian family
some of them don't it really depends on
we went to the states and we change the
entire economic structure I'm trying a
few mixtapes gentlemen in the park yeah
we're just weeded helped yeah I knew the
woman got ripped off as soon as she said
to me are there a hundred thousand
homeless in New York as soon as she said
that I'm like who beat you out of what
yeah like what did you get beaten out of
well those look the type of stats you
can't put on a soundcloud up yeah by the
way it's one of those questions where
I'm like I don't know probably yeah like
it's I don't know it sounds high but
then it also sounds low like I don't
it's one of those stats where you don't
really know I'm like I don't know I'm
like I don't know I'm homeless I think I
don't know if I yeah I don't somebody
told he's like hey I ain't slam I
slinging the CDs the harder he goes are
you mentioned the homeless yeah the
homeless in New York yeah well that's
the thing it's like you can't just you
can't just lead with the music you got a
lead with a social ill yeah children
work well yeah my grandma got gangrene
can you borrow my out yeah yeah is there
anyway is it true that everybody's
grandmother he has gangrene is that is
that true does every elderly person have
a flesh-eating bacteria in New York is
that true he showed me his foot $80 on a
CD for a man whose grandmother has
necrotizing fasciitis
he felt like he deserved it and he's
working for it that's one of those
diseases I I really like you know I I'm
a serious or was a serious hypochondriac
and I still kind of [ __ ] with it a
little bit oh yeah but you know
necrotizing fasciitis which is the
flesh-eating back every now and then a
kid goes swimming in a lake and then 3/4
of his body is like eaten by a
flesh-eating bacteria
that's terrifying I know dude there's
this girl I used to work with she got
bit by a black widow and it looked like
that [ __ ] like it really yeah it was
like the spidering veins coming out and
then she she just cut it open that
doctors did and it looked like she just
had a vagina on the side of her leg
really dude I'm telling you it was the
most disgusting thing I'd ever seen and
I it it terrified I'm still more
terrified of spiders today listen a lot
it's rare that you'll die I did a report
on spiders in eighth grade
really yeah I did I did a report on
spiders I it was from my science fair
that's another way it like the science
fair you're supposed to do like an
experiment the teacher was like this is
nothing to do
I brought a tarantula in from a pet
store yeah the teacher was like this is
nothing you know all the other kids did
like experiments like the volcano yeah
or like this is how water changes from a
gas to a solid she's like your science
fair project is just that there are
spiders she's like this is because I
just loved spy I'm like yeah there's
business a tarantula did you're a weird
kid I was weird I was just also like I
thought it was funny and cool that I
just brought a spider in and the teacher
was like this checks off none of the
boxes of what a technical science fair
project is supposed to be but I got to
have a spider for a week and the only
way that I was able to do that he's
telling my mother that I need it for a
science fair project is for school yeah
yeah so I'm like we got to go get a
tarantula dude my girl just did a
science science fair how old she's 9 ok
and she literally I went and saw it at
the school I didn't want to say anything
right but like everybody else that
looked nice their parents obviously
helped more than we did and hers we let
her cut it you know it's her science
project I'm there to guide but I got
video games to play and yeah she's 9 she
hasn't figured it out by now
exactly never will yeah I'm with you
she's got to learn learn how to fail
right right yeah but hers is literally
just a bunch of oranges in a plastic cup
like it was like a two gallon jug of
water that we cut the top off of and
there's oranges in there and it's
supposed to be whether oranges float
with the peel on or the peel ah
and so but when we went there there was
no water
it was just oranges this is like an
autistic science it's like a weird
obsession for anyone to have they're
just excited get the kids involved in a
scientific process you know what I mean
what
great about the science fairs you can
really see whose parents should be in
jail you know by what a kid will come in
with the social services at the door
like some crackhead kid will come in
like his parents of crack ads he'll come
in with like the poster boards not even
done
you know the oak tag he's got like
papers that aren't you this like he hand
wrote it and he just glued it on yeah
everyone else all the other kids have
like you know just like post like cards
that are like like you know ya fixed
onto the oak tag it looks really nice
it's colorful it's attractive he just
ripped the paper out of the one of those
binders with all the spools on the side
so it's all frayed yeah this poor kids
just [ __ ] sitting there at his dining
room table trying to do this while his
parents cook up a rock in the next room
and like you know they just walk out
look at it and they go this is it'll do
yeah that's fine son glad Timmy's
getting involved we're just glad he's
participating yeah they're I mean I was
in a few of those houses when I was
growing up because I I was a you know I
was a I was a hooligan I was a kid that
wanted to like get drugs all the time
yeah right you never smoked crack did
you rob I freebase cocaine okay and I
remember one of the funniest the Jamie
is crack yeah we did we took rocks a cup
we didn't cook it off to make it crack
but we put him in a we freebase again
and it was basically crowd I was
somebody in the house said to us they're
like this is basically cracked we just
laughed so hard we were 14 it was one of
those times we just laugh we're smoking
crack and we're just like they're like
this is basically crack and I look at my
buddy and I what this is we're basically
smoking crack and he we just we fell
down laughing it was just one of those
middle school memories that a lot of
people but like I would every now and
then like God there was this kid Ryan
whose parents were drunks and like you
know and we went like once we went into
his house to smoke some weed and he's
like hey before you go in the air you
know my house kind of dirt he was like
ashamed of it you know I was like dude I
hang out at I'm not gonna say their
names but I was like I hang out at blank
plant you know which it was the coke
house in town and ya know I know when he
kind of
I was like I don't give a [ __ ] did but a
lot of my childhood was spent in
absolutely filthy houses with like
cigarette burns in the carpet ashtrays
overflowing with cigarette Dutch cots
everywhere
what Dutch guts you know vanilla Duchess
people smoked blondes oh yeah yeah just
tobacco all over the place
oh yeah those shitty linoleum kitchen
floors
you know stains in the carpet you know
one leather couch that you pull a
cigarette stain blanket over yourself
and maybe take a half-hour nap that's
great yeah that's great I don't trust
anybody who hasn't pulled a cigarettes
and ratty blanket over themselves on a
[ __ ] coming down from coke trying not
to die the rats keep you warm yeah I
mean my friend Michael just got an
apartment and this guy's like he's the
only friend I made that I made from the
podcast and I met him he came to the
show at the stand once and he was he
came he's a good-looking guy you know
[ __ ] a lot of chicks successful guy not
crazy successful but you know in uh you
know he's doing the right thing the tim
dylan demographic well listen to the
show I imagine not I imagine he's kind
of an outlier I don't know who's out
there but I'll tell you right now from
the messages I get I would imagine that
he's in the top 1% of people that listen
to this show just in the sense that he's
always had his freedom you know but the
first time I met him he was bleeding
like I said to him like he came up with
a huge fan of the show and I looked at
him I'm like dude you're bleeding his
arm was bleeding and he just kind of
laughed it off how it was bleeding and
that's a sincere compliment though if
you if a man goes out of his way who's
actively bleeding to tell you he likes
something you're doing you're on the
right track
yeah no he he's one of these dudes who
women love them and guys like but
there's a certain type of dude who like
wants to be taken seriously by dudes and
is it yeah and
because he's like the dude who [ __ ]
everybody's check but I don't mean that
he Fox everyone's check
I just mean he's to do that gets [ __ ]
yeah and he's devoted a lot of time and
energy to that and by the way I was
telling him tonight I'm like dude you
have a better lot like we were talking
about our lives and I'm like yeah I've
been able to do some cool [ __ ] but I
kind of just would like sometimes I just
want to look like him and just [ __ ] yeah
you know what I mean yeah any not that's
the goal but he's like he's a cab he
goes you know but then you're like not
you don't feel the pressure to like be
successful and like do things or
whatever so it's like whatever the grass
is greener but I'm just like if I look
like you I would just [ __ ] surfers all
day I'd have AIDS and wouldn't care oh
yeah you know what I mean like I do I
wouldn't care I would I would want to be
like you know like I would just be like
so hot or I'd be like right before I
[ __ ] somebody be like I have AIDS in
this dude the good guy would be like who
cares that's wrong the dice tonight and
he's not an amazing looking guy he's
good enough looking he's thin he's just
thin yeah and that's where it's at yeah
you know what I mean that's like been
over here I mean he's he's a
good-looking guy he could be bigger be
Bonin down all over town and stayin
Michael's got a sexual energy yeah like
Michael's like he's in it to [ __ ] yeah
you can feel it bet Ben's better-looking
than Michael but like Michael just get
like Michael could just go in and just
[ __ ] yes that guy yeah when you're
sitting at a table with him he like want
you know he wants to be [ __ ] yeah
that's like trying to do this other
thing
and like ask me about my podcast like he
gives a [ __ ] you know yeah and he does
he does care but he just wants to be
[ __ ] some 19 year old girl with USC
and I get it you know what I mean I get
it but he also like he's you know so I
was just like you know so he just gets
his but he's also a guy who like always
makes the wrong decisions when it comes
to like where he live like he makes
these bad real estate decisions like and
he loves complaining about them and he's
a guy not in a funny way like there are
people like there are people that just
do things
yeah so they can complain about them
yeah like he moved in he comes out to LA
yeah you know him and his he him and he
met some dude some guy who's another
good-looking in shape guy who happened
to be a psychopath and he didn't know
this but he like moved in with this guy
and then like a day later the guy is
like the guy has all these mental
problems the guys got us some girlfriend
in New York the guy that could put the
guys like all over the place the guy
tells Michael he moves in with Michael
yeah and then he tells him he goes like
as Michael's moving in he goes you know
I went on a my uncle's a rich guy used
to take us on vacation and I I woke up
one day and he and his hand down my
pants when I was like how long have they
known each other literally hours moving
in the boxes right there eating Chinese
food together discouraged so Michaels
like oh okay you know hey you know this
is good story
yeah so and then the guy goes says to
him he goes I just kept going on
vacation with him kept kind of happening
but you know you had a lot of money
whatever and so like Michael tells me
this and I'm like yeah I'm telling you
right now telling you right now telling
you right now you made a big mistake
again yeah yeah this is a big big
mistake Michael's like yeah this guy
seems like a real problem the kid would
be like crying like you come home really
yeah and then the kids like and
Michael's like I don't really know if I
could live with you and the kids like
but I still want to be friends with you
I thought you're one of my best friends
literally they know each other do 48
hours at this point like so I'm like oh
this is total but one of the reasons
Michael likes means he's attracted to
crazy people he likes crazy people yeah
they're know what I need yeah yeah but
my I've I have to monetize my crazy so
there's a limit to how crazy I can get
yeah I have to be crazy in the in the
parameters of civil society yeah you
know what I mean absolutely but this
dude that's not so he would come home
and the kid would be and then the kids
start saying I'm like if you leave I
don't know what I'll do man I'm afraid
of myself I don't know if he's
threatening Michael or threatening to
kill him so finally and they just moved
in together or they just literally said
there are its this is all under 72 hours
cheese the kid is threatening to harm
himself
saying cuz the kids on drugs he's got
all these problems and Michael's calling
me is like I'm so mad at myself I don't
know why I did this and I'm like I know
why you did it cuz you were just like
you saw a beautiful apartment yeah this
kid seemed like whatever but you know so
he then gets this apartment now he's
living in this place a Marina del Rey
no marina no Marina del Rey here's the
thing man here's a thing here
I got a you know and he's like he's one
of my best friends and he knows he knows
that I have to broadcast this you know
to hundreds of thousands of people it is
what it is with your friends with me my
parents know this date you know yeah I'm
I want to do lie pockets for my mother's
mental institution but all of the people
I want to have on keep dying and so it's
like oh this is tough but I'm like I'm
one of the inmates you could call them
patients but they can't leave yeah yeah
so inmate is fine for that I know you
know I know we want to be all sweet on
them but a patient can go outside the
inmate you know what I mean and my
mother can go out but it's you go to
sign a waiver and take her out and bring
it back in you know oh yeah so swap
responsibilities so Michael goes and
gets this apartment in like you know
this this like it looks like a hotel
it looks like an older hotel it's like
one of these complex is popcorn ceilings
you know those like ceilings it's all
carpet the holy his apartment is all
carpet the holes are carpeted there's
stains everywhere the holes are carpet
holes
oh the halls the holes you know there's
no smell great it looks like the hotel
from the Florida project you know yeah
but with none of like the fun people but
maybe there are some fun people like
yeah I think you smoke a little weed in
his apartment and
he got a note slipped under the door and
they're like hey I'm on dialysis I can't
close the window I'm not strong enough
to open the window please you know
there's a lot of dangers a secondhand
smoke and he was just like okay you know
you like a lot of positives of smoking
weed though if you're on dialysis right
right yeah but he you know so who knows
he's probably getting blamed for a lot
of other [ __ ] that's going on there but
like nobody forced him to make this
decision right yeah and the place has a
pool and whatever yeah and it's you know
I walk in and I'm like you know this is
it she's spending like 2,400 a month
twenty-five hundred a month Oh sh in
view stop he's like I'm two blocks from
the beat here's the thing folks what is
this need to live by the beach
what psychosis is this like I'm two
blocks from the beach you're either on
the beach or you're not yeah I'm an hour
from the beach same [ __ ] you either on
the beach or you're not on the beach you
have to put the shoes on or you don't
beach towns are disgusting they're full
of drunks junkies true yeah people that
are attracted to the beach ten percent
of them are upstanding people that want
a jog and do volleyball and the other
ninety percent of them are homeless
heroin addicts yeah so every beat Venice
you go down to Venice it's like who
would want to live in this I would
rather live at the gathering of the
Juggalos then live in these beach tent
like even Malibu is dirty and [ __ ] like
I understand if you have a mansion and
you have a view of whatever but it's
filthy it's filthy and I'm a water guy
I'm a beach guy I love it I grew up in a
beach town I get it yeah you know what
we used to do when I grew up on the
beach we used to sniff cocaine on it at
night and like all the people that
bought house
[ __ ] like who these dirtbags yeah we're
kids
what the hell's this why is this you
know smoking weed and doing blow on a
beat that's what people do on the beach
it's a good time
so he's like yeah she walked through the
beach and and then he starts saying
things he's like you know he's a guy
with like very specific complaints he's
like there's nowhere to get an $8 food
item here yeah no [ __ ]
I'm like yeah he's like it's either a
lot of money or it's like is it you just
know where to get an eighth of it and he
acts like he was you know somebody at
gunpoint put a gun in his mouth dragged
him into this place and said sign this
lease or we're gonna blow your brains
out of the back of your skull that's
what he acts like but he did this
completely voluntarily because he kind
of likes I think there's some apart you
know cuz he's like he's like all the
things that are better a35 and I can't
you know I can't spend that mine I can't
so I have to get I have to be in this
and it's just one of those things where
it's like you know at a certain point
you just you got to realize if you keep
making these decisions there's a reason
you keep making them there's it yeah
easy to keep making them you you know
you want to be in a position that you
don't and and I it is what it it I'm not
judging anybody I've made a lot of bad
choices no in my life but not the bad
choices than anyone thinks right you're
not signing leases on shitty shitty of
course on anything you know yeah is it
thing I sign was a mortgage no for six
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
it's a good advanced guess what that
didn't work out well for me or the
people that gave me six hundred and
seventy thousand dollars when I was
coked out in twenty three years old and
I showed up in a sweaty coke panic
signing papers that's the last thing I
sighs dude that now that but that was
the sign of the times I mean that's
that's how you did a loan science if you
didn't buy a house with a subprime
mortgage and lose it you're a [ __ ] yeah
straight up
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you didn't go
on the [ __ ] ride like all of us good
Americans yeah then [ __ ] you did I was I
had a showdown in this country yeah I
was right there with you
there's no debtors prison this isn't
Dubai where they lock you up in jail cuz
you can't pay for something yeah just
declare bankruptcy declaring bankruptcy
which I haven't done and I will probably
but eventually maybe I don't know but
the clearing better you buy a nice
fridge before you do I will celebrate my
bankruptcy at a beautiful restaurant in
Beverly Hills like I don't people say to
me all you defend Kabbalist I don't
really different capitalism only know
about capitalism is you borrow a lot of
money you don't pay it back and no one
can put you in a Cell yeah that's my
understanding of capitalists the
American Dream that now it hurts your
kids or whoever's around for it I'm I'm
not advising this but I'm a lone wolf
here I'm wandering around the desert
alone if you hand me a big money and
saying this will work out I'm gonna say
you better well I bet it will why am I
gonna tell you do I know better than
Wells Fargo what I need no and they said
I needed a bag of money and I was
inclined to agree with them uh Wells
Fargo baby
but Michaels a legit guy he's got credit
he's a real person yeah hot little
girlfriend who's a nurse yeah they could
make a real [ __ ] life of it you know
and you know just I don't know he's
working he's he's in the weed thing now
he came out here to get into this weed
business cuz he had a really good job
Fanta and and he wanted to come out here
and he got rid of that job but he wanted
to come out here because listen unless
you get involved in one of these
businesses that the potential to make a
lot of money yeah it you know Mawile
dwells out here with weed you know yeah
laws are changing every day
companies are emerging people trying to
there's a huge group of people that come
out to this state with law degrees that
want to be consultants that want to take
a lot of these mostly illegal operations
and make them legal and there's a lot of
people that are that are trying to get
in that business and I think he was in a
position in his company where he's like
I'll make 150 grand a year every year
till I'm dead go to Mets games have a
nice house on Long Island or
let me [ __ ] take a shot I think you
saw a guy like me who was [ __ ] taking
a shot you know I make tens of thousands
of dollars a year you know I have
hundreds of fans and I think he saw that
and he said I want to be I want to be a
guy like Tim who puts it all on the line
you know so that he can [ __ ] stay in
his friend spare room every now and then
that's what he want and that type of
inspiration is why I'm here I'm here
so that people that have good lives can
throw them away in the hopes that
there's something great on the other
side of it because [ __ ] I was on a
podcast people listened to ya know
you've made it you made it people think
I am like yeah he's people
somebody said to me the other day like
you're probably getting ready to buy a
house I'm like I'm getting ready to buy
a gun are you not I make no money and
all the money I make is take it from me
for my agent my manager yep
who deserve that occasionally my agent
does and my manager is I'll enjoy him
you know and so what you sleep I make a
third of my money and then there's taxes
and then there's you know so but but I
do think there's a lot of risk and it's
exciting and I get that yeah to a guy
like him and you know we've had talks
about this he's like I want to do
something exciting
you know I want to be part of it I want
to be a millionaire I wanna I want to
have all that he put with what I think
he doesn't realize is it like none of
that really MEK it's good and it's great
to make money but I don't think it
matters in the way that he thinks it
matters like I think like if fulfillment
wise yeah because at the end of the day
I think what he doesn't realize is that
the people that make that kind of money
their entire less you get really lucky
yeah their entire life is dedicated to
making that kind of money right
everything they do uh you know people
when people think about making money
they think about vacations they think
about oh this is the house I live in and
the rich people that I know when they're
on a vacation they're there they're not
even on it mentally they're somewhere
else that give out their [ __ ] business
thinking about you know they're on the
phone on a beach
we're yelling at somebody right on %
yeah so I think that there's you know
because he works for you know people
that are you know really committed to
but you know he sees you know
first-class airfare the big house is the
big money unless you want that and I get
it and God bless and I hope he makes all
the money he wants yeah you know what I
mean I thinks all the money wants and
he'll be very happy you know it was nice
about him is he he doesn't you know he
knows you the apartment is [ __ ] yeah so
that I don't have to pretend like you
know this is it reminded me one of the
crack houses I hung out at when I was 13
I'm like sure we start crushing up rocks
like what do we what are we doing here
Marina del Rey yeah why are you living
well I'm by the beach I try to walk down
to the beach every day before work why
why again you're having it that's not a
rich thought that's not a rich person
thought before work there is no before
work and there's no after work
there's just [ __ ] work yeah what are
you going around [ __ ] with seals in
the morning yeah he's like you know
sometimes I could maybe I jump in the
water in the day do day you've not
earned the beach
you've not earned the beach you get no
beach that's a great John Mulaney joke
where he talks about all these house
hunters shows where John Mulaney is like
and now another episode of oh who
doesn't deserve a beach house
you know folks may 16th I'm at left
Boston June 20th to the 23rd I'm at
Mohegan Sun you want tickets to these go
look at the new website we have for the
show and my stand-up dates using Wix Tim
Dylan's going to hell calm
TI MDI ll ons going to hell calm we
don't have the is because some [ __ ]
already owns that he thinks we're gonna
go to some bidding war we're not okay
you can also go there to check out past
audio and video episodes of the podcast
Wix is the best and easiest way to
create professional websites okay you
can start from scratch or choose over
500 stunning templates they have a very
innovative drag-and-drop website builder
it's the world's most innovative you can
easily customize your site add text
images videos whatever you want you can
even use their Wix Adi artificial design
intelligence just answer a few simple
about what the nature of your businesses
and they will design a site that helps
you get out there under the world I've
talked about the need for a website
before a lot of people don't think they
need a website they're dead [ __ ] wrong
they think they could just go on social
media put all their content on Instagram
next to a photo of them having a hotdog
or next to a photo of a [ __ ] cute dog
they saw this doesn't [ __ ] work be a
professional you need a web site you
need some type of home for all of your
content doesn't really matter what you
do okay I have a website everyone I know
has my there's no successful person out
there that doesn't have a [ __ ]
website okay I guarantee you even the
guys the Instagram youtuber guys they
all have [ __ ] websites okay online is
the future folks everything you love is
over everything you're used to is over
radios done TV is done the family is
done government is done God is done all
of those things are done now you can be
upset about that that might bother you
some of you and maybe some of you have a
point I don't know I don't have time to
litigate the issue with you but I'll
tell you for a fact every institution
that has given you comfort in the world
has crumbled your children will not grow
up with these institutions they will
grow up in a chaotic Mad Max situation
where groups of people fight each other
for food water and resources they will
grow up in a world where there is no
objective truth or reality but they will
decide what objective truth and reality
they want to live in and they will be
aided by technology they will grow up in
a virtual reality sphere and the only
thing that will interrupt that is the
bombing or the firing of a gun which I
imagine will happen all the time
depending on how quickly the resources
evaporate and how aggressive climate
change is and how many people are
displaced again this is what I think in
a time like that imagine not having a
website he would have to be insane to
not have a website during such a period
of uncertainty a website is a great
place to dock your boat your boat being
your content your social media your
links who you are and you got to do it
here's the other thing folks go to Tim
Dylan's going to hell calm D I ll oh and
s going to hell calm know is click the
link at the bottom Wix gives you 10% off
any premium plan and I've said this
before and I will say this again if you
prove to me if you send me a screenshot
that you purchased the Wix premium plan
through my site I will give you three
minutes on this show to advertise
whatever you're doing we have an
audience of tens of thousands of people
a lot of people here okay not quite a
hundred but we're almost there's a lot
of people listening so if you have two
to three minutes or you want to tell me
to go [ __ ] myself and you hate me you
want to threaten me whatever you want to
do threaten my family I don't give a
[ __ ] you can do it if you buy the Wix
premium plan through my website and get
the 10% off you get three minutes on
this show minimum if you're good we will
go longer with you many of you will not
be good you're not broadcasters you
don't your thoughts have no value many
of you the majority of you out there
your thoughts have no value but maybe
they do maybe I'm wrong about that
you'll get three minutes on Tim Dylan's
going to hell all it will cost you is a
Wix premium plan that you purchase how
you go to Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
D il L ons going to hell calm and click
the link at the bottom you could also
buy tickets for my upcoming stand-up
appearances there and you could check
out some audio video archives of the
podcast there too it's a great one-stop
shop you could check out my Rogen
episode you could check out other
podcasts I've done anything you want you
can do on the site it's a great place to
[ __ ] around and see what I'm all about
okay which will give you 10% off any
premium plan that's where we are so
again what is coming down the pike
chaos food shortages war political
corruption virtual reality augmented
reality it's gonna be like Pokemon go
times a thousand people are gonna be in
the street thinking that they're
fighting white walkers cuz there's some
new Game of Thrones augmented reality
game they'll all [ __ ] be playing
it'll little be literal hell it'll be a
insane asylum every single day
we're completely the robots are coming
they're taking over we're gonna be
policed by that Boston Dynamics company
big robotic dogs on the street tearing
people apart and gnashing at their teeth
that is what's coming and in that
climate do you want to walk around and
not have a website do you not want to
have a place for your content and if you
don't have content now it's over you're
dead you don't exist [ __ ] your family
they don't matter your children and your
significant others do not matter what
matters is your content what are you
putting out into the world is it quick
is it cheap is it ultimately useless
that's what content is is it good for a
few minutes and then it goes away
doesn't stand the test of time it's not
long-lasting or important but you just
throw it out into the ether try to
monetize it and then die that is what
your life is feed the beast
okay and you can do it by going to Tim
Dylan's going to hell calm and signing
up for a free offer Platinum membership
on Wix and getting 10% off thanks so
much I've been watching those and I
never got any of them but I've been
watching them more and more where people
I like the ones that are in real
[ __ ] areas mm-hmm
where it's like the realtors look like
[ __ ] and they show up without shoes on
yeah and they're selling people like
just $300,000 beach houses in Mobile
Alabama salt of the earth yes
the earth people and you know mobile I
what I was when I was a kid I was I was
in Annie Get Your Gun which was a show
that was on Broadway they toured it
around the country I was 11 years old I
lived on a you know we stayed in
different hotels every night but I lived
on a tour bus I went to Mobile Alabama
and you know there the you know Mobile
Alabama is I saw the thing that I I went
on one of those rides where they they
pull you up in a harness and then let
you swing and it's still there like
eyelid um real estate so we're talking
talking 20 years ago more than 20 years
ago the same ride like yeah Mobile but
it's just funny when the realtor is like
you know they're they're telling these
people like about all the different you
know things that the house has and all
the people like really excited they're
like you can't you can't beat these
views can't beat it you can't beat these
views and it's like yeah but let's let's
be honest you're gonna be in the house
and you're gonna for a lot of the people
on that show not all of them but for a
lot of the people on that show you'd be
just as happy getting drunk and posting
about queueing on somewhere else you
don't need to be on the beach to post
about queueing on on Reddit in a
methamphetamine haze you don't need to
be get away stop this I like to be doing
my post song on when I want full on
crack cocaine when I was an extra
bedroom and I like this town it's real
quite you could walk everywhere anyway
once Hana Mo's being kept open because
Barack and Hillary are going to jail for
running a human trafficking ring and
Trump was sent by Jesus it's like okay
but this could go on a few blocks away
from the beach
probably check me out at Trump Soldier
69 on the
yeah I'm sure you could really light up
our the Donald from another location
that isn't you know really I don't think
you need seagulls [ __ ] on your head
do my wife water my wife will watch that
show and just I just will feel so shitty
while she watches it because we're
sitting in this two-bedroom apartment in
Sunland with our two kids and you know
we've got a guy a streetwalker that just
walks into people's houses just some
random vagrant that's literally just
open just seeing if people's doors are
open and and see if they got food in
their house some dude did that to our
downstair neighbor I gotta be honest
with ya I'm trying to think of how
different that guy's life is from mine
really that different at all place open
they got sandwiches yeah that's kind of
what I do just walking around knocking
on doors but we'll watch these shows and
they'll be guys like in Mobile or there
was some random middle of the country
place and they're buying these
gargantuan 10,000 square foot homes
yeah and it's just like well this one's
a real fixer-upper
you know it's 97 thousand dollars I know
that's a bit above your budget but we
know what if we if we do this we could
put a lot of improvements you know well
what's great what you learn about those
shows is you just you're if you don't
have to live in New York or LA you're
you're kind of free absolutely you know
there's an amazing freedom you get from
just being able to go somewhere else
because some of these [ __ ] houses
they'll be like this house is 7,000
square feet though it's eighteen
bedrooms 16 bathrooms pool you know and
it's like a $300,000 yeah because you're
living in the middle of the woods and
like I love like you know they'll tell
them they're like you won't see any
neighbors you're out here you're
secluded you're living in the [ __ ]
woods yeah some of them though they're
like the guy my favorite ones are the
ones where one of them will have like an
archery range in the backyard and then
though it's a shitty house and then
they'll show them two other houses and
the guy will be like if I'm honest I
really want that archery range yeah it's
like you know you can put that at any of
the other houses but you can't see
beyond you know beYOU know and I also
love the people on those shows who
clearly inherited all the money I don't
even know what a monthly payment is or
what a mortgages yeah they have little
no clue and they're like it's time to
get a home we live in a house right now
and by the way I'm imitating southern
people I know that they're not all set
don't [ __ ] start a problem with me
and tell me that they're not all
southern I just can't do a lot of
[ __ ] accents put a lot of the more
you know they have like I don't even
know exist and be like I want to get a
beach house in Gainesville Florida yeah
I want to get a second home for my
family down in Gainesville
I want a fan boat you know something to
go ahead and knock the Gator heads
around you know and they'll be like
local realtor Susan Coleman Eddie's here
her she's here to show this couple some
options for beach house in Gainesville
Florida now Susan's son is incarcerated
recently she barricaded herself in the
bathroom while he tried to break down
the door to steal the rest of her pain
medication Susan sadly had to put him in
jail where she hopes he'll find Jesus
Susan's out here trying to show this
other couple what beach house in
Gainesville Florida in a swamp is best
to suit their needs
these Realtors look Haggard on these
shows oh yeah
these Realtors oh that betta like beat
up they're wearing like beaters yeah
these Realtors a lot of them are women
yeah they show up looking like you know
like complected with purple lipstick Oh
dark eyeliner pencil thin eyebrows yet
they show up and they're just it the
whole thing is super awkward once we get
the possums out of the garage this place
is gonna be great yeah they're like and
and the thing about real estate is like
there's not a ton of middle ground so
there's people that make a lot of money
at it and then there's people and it's
kind of like comedy it's like people who
really aren't Realtors but they have
they passed that test oh yeah you know
so they're just they don't know [ __ ]
yeah they don't know anything and
they're just kind of stumbling around a
house yeah showing these other
degenerates you
dude I I read you know the Robert
Kiyosaki's The Millionaire Next Door or
whatever yeah one of those books about
real estate and I thought oh it's on now
I'm gonna I'm gonna start getting real
estate and start renting it out and
nobody knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
like you go to these places that guy I
remember some guy tried to get us to go
to a conference for $3,000 and we show
up at the conference and the lady at the
front desk doesn't even know what's
going on this is like a preview yeah
show up well the first days free and if
you want to do the full thing you know
and then we found it was 3 grand while
we're in the conference but the guy's
advice was go and look on the newspaper
for houses yeah that was his advice yeah
look if you go get a paper your local
paper yeah you go when you look at
there's houses for sale right and you
can buy now sometimes you go and you
can't get a loan maybe not a problem go
in there see if they'll be financed
alone for ya know the state is like a
business for people who think books are
gay you know that's like the people that
get into real estate are [ __ ]
even then even the ones that make
millions of dollars a year they're
stupid people and they have like they're
dumb they're not smart so even the big
ones and I make it ten million dollars a
year in New York art simply can only
talk about tile in a bathroom yeah they
have no idea what's going on they have
no idea they it's that sales ethos yeah
I'm not concentrating on anything else
except making the sale so they don't
care they will sell hot like there's
tents all over LA that these people
drive by people are literally like it's
it's it's [ __ ] post-apocalyptic war
zone these people drive through it they
don't even look at it don't think about
it don't care listening to some [ __ ]
motive it you know dude and then they
just go walk around the house and
they're like there's a lot of natural
light there's a lot of light in the sun
room and it's like well that's nice
society's crumbling have you thought of
that guy that's where I would suck at
that job because I would in the middle
of the sale I would look at the people
get did you see the tents by the way he
like how until that just
you know boils over and what happens do
you think those people get weapons
eventually anyway yeah there is light
here I guess in the room you can keep
the swing set in the backyard
agents and managers none of these people
are there were so few smart people in
the world there's not a lot of smart
people and sales is not a job for smart
people it's a job and but you need
salespeople I respect the hell out of
sales but I would rather hang out with
them than these [ __ ] of there's a lot
of pseudo-intellectual people who think
that they're intelligent right but what
that really means is they have no social
skills so you have a lot of artists
running around places that can't speak
to a human being without being terrified
right if you say hello to them they act
like you played a cruel joke so so they
tend to think they're intelligent
because they read you know marks all day
and then you stumble out to an open mic
but so I'd rather that I rather some
dumb hot salesperson who's just coming
all over and [ __ ] hot and dumb as
[ __ ] and just cares about but then
there's a limit to you know those people
also you're like okay enough is enough
did I used to work I wasn't used to work
sales at Wells Fargo and yeah this girl
came in after like about Wells Fargo's
that's a company it'll just bang an old
person right over there dude I got a
story for you man but this I remember
this girl came in for a job interview
and she literally had a huge scar over
her neck like she tried to behead
herself yeah and it was red and she was
like a real pale skin and it was just so
obvious like it was just ridiculous and
this she leaves and I go to my manager I
go what do we are we gonna hire he goes
I don't know and I go what's with the
scar though you didn't think that would
be a little off-putting to people and he
goes look man she's hungry okay alright
he's like that's all we need I just need
somebody that's hungry and it has no
morals and then you're just is willing
to do whatever it takes to get the sale
I'm like eh fair enough that's what it
is
matter there is this this guy in if it's
that guy from the last scene of
Beetlejuice with that little head and he
wants to crush it he's hungry and
aggressive on to be aggressive and crush
he told me he loves the phones as long
as there's not one thought that goes
through his head that doesn't correlate
to [ __ ] selling whatever horseshit
you've decided people need you know did
we had some guy in his 80s who had a
house in Fresno Fresno Central Valley
California and the house was worth 750
grand we somehow were able to bump the
value to get him a 1.2 million dollar
loan and the lady that comes in and
signs it is like this
decent looking woman in the 30s with
these huge six-inch heels on and she
he's over in the chair just kind of like
slumped over barely conscious and she's
just going well honey if we do this then
we can get the pool we can get that pool
maybe even the boat we were talking
about gas and he's just like barely just
barely conscious yeah that woman by the
way they'll write an article about her
that she's a victim oh yeah you know
she's a victim this woman yes like I
told that story the other week of the
pot it's like the idea that these people
are victims is kind of right but I
listen I love sales because if there's
something cool about a sales office
because literally it's not you know when
you look at certain businesses the
people especially the one that we're in
a lot of the writers are all Ivy [ __ ]
boys they all [ __ ] come from the same
place sales office dude you love people
you love an 80 year old guy selling [ __ ]
just cuz he's like I'm trying to stay
alive yeah and I like I do appreciate it
something about that I appreciate
dude this guy Keith would come into and
into work and that the hot news every
day would be what he found last night
right as he was a speed head and he
would just he would to be like dude I
got some nice brass real nice brass last
night it was a big hall yes I own my
truck was almost fold up and I you know
we bets I barely got to work on time is
some of the most fun there was this guy
named Howie I used to work with who was
a cocaine dealer and also sold mortgages
but didn't really sell mortgages because
he didn't really
know what they were but he was like and
he was like a 40 year old guy mid-30s at
that point who she should have known and
I remember just being 19 and sitting in
his apartment and watching him like do
cocaine and he's like I want to move to
Santa Domingo he goes because that's
where they treat you like a [ __ ]
person that's where they treat you like
a [ __ ] person and I was all coked out
just staring at him yeah yeah man yeah
those are dark times and then I've gotta
those were dark times and then you get
in a comment and you're like oh those
were great like those yeah yeah we're
fine
those people were I somebody messaged me
on Instagram saying thank you for
plugging better help calm because better
help actually helped this person okay
and this is true better help and I've
tried it out myself because I don't want
to try things here that I didn't it is a
professional company and it is something
where they're literally trying to help
people and there's a lot of people out
there you know specifically in my
audience probably I don't know I'm just
guessing we're criminally insane
mentally ill they're unwell okay uh
there Wacka dues they're batshit crazy
whatever term you want to use you know
um my mother you know there she's a nut
she's a schizophrenic we call her a nut
she's a nut you know I don't view any of
those terms of derogatory I think quite
honestly they're appropriate and better
help online counseling is a great new
advancement in how to get people to help
that they need okay it offers
professional licensed counselors who
specialize in issues like depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
anger family conflicts self-esteem and
more better help lets you connect with
your professional counselor at a safe
and private online environment anything
you share is confidential and so it's
convenient you can now get help at your
own time and at your own pace you don't
have to leave your house because we all
know that's where the problems are
that's where the people are that's where
the open spaces are that's where all of
the underground tunnels are that's where
it all can go wrong that's where you can
get snatched up and put in a van so you
don't leave you stay comfy and cozy in
your apartment eating Nutella with your
thumb what
ever and you can get help okay it's very
hard for me to find time in my busy
schedule for mental health also I've
monetized my insanity which actually
provides me not exactly the best you
know not exactly you know doesn't give
me a real [ __ ] what word am I looking
for here what is the word I'm looking
for Bobby it doesn't give me a real
motivation what's the word though I
don't know well anyway being close
relation know whatever it is I'm trying
to say I'm not really motivated to fix
any of my problems because in comedy we
take those problems we make them funny
it's the deal with the devil we make and
it's why we all die and burn in hell but
you may not feel that way nor should you
so you should check out better help calm
slash Tim Dylan get started today simply
fill out a questionnaire to help them
assess your needs and get matched with a
professional counselor you'll love these
are real counselors they're real people
they're not your shitty friends stop
telling your friends your problems you
don't have any friends friends are an
illusion stop telling your family your
problems your family in most cases holds
you back
they won't they smother you to try to
keep you down you have to get rid of
them get rid of your friends get rid of
your family and keep a significant other
only if they try to aid you in your
quest for power um better help you see
how much better helps help me I didn't
even know those things before I started
going to better help
I started going getting getting this
counselor started to tell me all this
[ __ ] I wish I was a counselor I'm better
helped I would be so much [ __ ] better
I would be so much better if I was a
counselor I'm better helped because all
you [ __ ] need really is someone to
tell you that you suck and why that's
what counseling is you suck why why is
there a gorgeous man and woman having
satisfying sex in an apartment that they
[ __ ] own with jobs they kill it at
and why are you sitting around with your
mangy dog on a futon why because you
suck and I'll tell you why but I can't
won't hire me a better help they have
people there to try to [ __ ] really
help you get to the bottom of your
story whatever maybe you were sold into
sex slavery as a child you know why on
why everybody's got a problem
everybody's got boo boo hoo boo hello
give a [ __ ] what I'm saying though is
that it does help it does work for
people god I wished it hired me because
I'd give you [ __ ] - what for when you
that's what I'd say my family makes me
mad
families are for losers chapter one of
my new book be a [ __ ] person families
are for losers friends are for losers
are you a loser folks go to better help
calm / Tim Dillon okay you can really
get help it won't be me on the other
line sadly um and let me know listen if
you really sign up for better help it's
helping you message me tell me you like
it cuz sagai already did and I
appreciate that message I don't know I
think I responded I think I told him to
kill himself but I'm kidding I didn't I
didn't do that I said I'm glad I want
people to get help
you know a lot of people my help that
I'll give you many of you aren't ready
for you're not ready for the real truth
that's the problem with many of you
you're not ready for the real truth like
the people that followed Jim Jones
weren't ready for the truth so they had
to all drink that potion and they all
ended up in that field they took that
long nap Heaven's Gate they weren't
ready for the truth they were waiting
for the hale-bopp comet when I was a
child that a great cult called Heaven's
Gate and everybody waited for hell about
comet a spaceship that was riding behind
the comet to come get them they'll
attract poison and die
I imagine believing in something like
that that's your problem people you
don't believe in anything you ridicule
those people that died in that call they
knew purpose like you never will like
you never will so go to better help calm
/ Tim Dillon folks and really get on
board here because if you're lucky
you're one of those people that thought
that spaceship was coming behind a
comment they drank the poison and that's
what I'll turn all of you into if I were
to better help I would
new into people that believed in
something so [ __ ] much that you were
willing to drink poison and wait for a
spaceship coming behind the comet that
would be my goal but that's be honest
with you that's why they have not hired
me that's fine because I still think
they are a great service better help.com
slashed him Dylan go get help thank you
I got I got [ __ ] on the other day I
wrote this tweet about this movie love
Simon which is a movie I don't know if
you've seen love Sciences in book it
came out in 2015 and I tweet stuff and
every now and then people get enraged at
me but this was people really angry
because love Simon is about a gay guy
who court starts corresponding
anonymously with another person at his
school okay and he then struggles with
coming out of the closet and then he
comes out of the clouds but his parents
are like liberal and they have a
beautiful house in the suburbs and he's
gorgeous and everything works out at the
end and universe everything's fine and
so I tweeted out like listen this is you
know I understand but listen you know
let's stop pretending that in 2016
coming out is like it wasn't 1950 yeah
okay can we stop pretending that this
isn't angels in America where everyone's
dropping dead of AIDS and and basically
everyone else is going good good good
this is what's going on I'm not saying
that people don't have struggles with it
especially you know people have
different so I just tweeted like listen
I was like I have had conversations and
uber pools that are more worthy of being
a show it's 2019
yeah and the plotline is that this kid
in the suburbs is just like how do i how
do I do it how can I do it his friends
are all liberal friends not yeah you're
not living in the backwoods
some so I thought that would be an
innocuous thing and the the hate that I
got from people for laughs how people
got so angry on Twitter they're like
everybody's coming out story matters
number one it doesn't let me be very
clear about that
it doesn't matter I think people having
access to water matters yes to be you
know a hundred percent and and if
everyone's coming out story matters well
then no one's matters yes yep ah
some people come out it's a big deal
some of the thing some and I'm not
taking it might matter to you personally
but who gives a [ __ ] sure it doesn't
[ __ ] about so people call me
heterosexual they're like you're a
header you don't understand anything
about da da da da da you are and all
these people that are enraged are not
gonna read the tweets I don't I give
these [ __ ] people you know but it was
just kind of funny to me yeah that
people get so angry at the [ __ ] idea
that no you are not interesting
just because you you suck dick it
doesn't make you it might have been 97
yeah but we got other [ __ ] now yeah we
got 3,000 genders yeah we got we've got
other [ __ ] we've moved on now right it's
not now I know that people don't want to
trade that card in cuz then they have to
have something the [ __ ] I'm not
saying it's easy for gay people I know
that I passed as a straight person so
it's easier for me you know what I mean
that what it is that the people say
people are like well you pass as a
straight guy that's why you work comedy
clubs I said no there were stage C clubs
I make the people there laughs yeah paid
to be there I don't talk about come for
an hour yeah and I don't do a you know
like the iTalk about sexuality in the
act and it is with it like this whole
idea now it's like no I hate to say but
it's like it's no longer interesting
being gay is no longer interested yeah
it just isn't dude I got in trouble at a
Mike some some girl pulled me aside
outside and was just like you're you're
you're punching down because I said
I was just sitting in this mic and
everybody was going up there and
essentially their whole set was this is
who I [ __ ] and and nobody will take you
know be okay with it and they're glad
[ __ ] a dog it was a cry yeah yeah no one
cares
no I just I went onstage I were just
like I hope that there's more to you
than what you put your dick in or let
people put in you boiler alert there is
not many of these people there is not
and that's the problem yeah
many of these people I look at them I'm
like oh thank God you were gay because
if not you would be a [ __ ] you would be
a customer service rep at Geico and
there's nothing wrong with that but
that's what you would do your
conversations with people should consist
of this where you hit from behind or the
police on the way are you okay
has an ambulance showed up that's what
it is nobody needs your [ __ ] thoughts
your thoughts have no value right your
thoughts have no effect because you put
a dick in your mouth or you put your
tongue in a [ __ ] if your what whatever
do no one cares so my whole thing would
love Simon is and here's the other thing
right so I'll tell you about a love
Simon situation that I had is it another
reason that I might hate the movie
because I will now tell you but it's
about you but it doesn't what my loves
it you know the love Simon worked out
very nicely in this film and they ended
up this week hot black kid hot white kid
on a ferris wheel and it was the last
scene of the movie is like they meet
each other finally on this Ferris wheel
and they're like well aren't you happy
and not it or not and that's not what
always happens and it's unrealistic to
me but people like that people love that
sky of a bow on it and people want the
bow on it and they what they want it to
be but I used to there were these blogs
in like 2000 and again I want to say
this because I don't I never want to lie
to my audience people have remarked to
hear the show people said it sounds like
you're smoking a cigarette on the show
and I don't smoke and I've never smoked
and what they're hearing when I smoke a
cigarette they're hearing me enjoy a
pair oh that's yeah yeah
was wondering why you keep is very
healthy it doesn't see my pears are
healthy to be honest they're so good
there's a luscious haven't had one you
know in a while except now I'm having
one now well it's a podcast pear yeah
so that's what it is but I used there
were these blogs where there would be
these blogs would be like closeted frat
boy and closeted frat boy would write it
would be some kid who would be like in a
frat in like a school and you just write
about [ __ ] dudes on the DL and you
would read these blogs to really get off
that's why you would read oh yeah he
would tell some story about some guy
that he met and you know and there are
some frat guys I didn't know was like we
all got drunk and then we all you know I
was getting hazed with a paddle what
they did porn but then also these kids
but you would fall in love with these
guys if you kept read because you
identified with them you're like well
I'm in the closet and this person's in
the closet and dotted on a tie and
you're and they had the life that you
wanted they were they were you know
good-looking they were athletic and
there were all these things that you
wanted to be and they were [ __ ]
whatever so I started to correspond with
a guy who was this closeted financial
guy okay and he would write all these
dumb you know things about what it's
like to be a guy in the closet in the
finance world and he had graduated an
Ivy League school and whatever and I
just you I never saw his picture so I
would just imagine what he looked like
right so I would correspond with him
back and forth and you know he would
talk to me and I'd be like um you know
I'm a comedian and back then I was just
like really doing open mics and
everything I was trying to I thought so
you know this guy in his own apartment
that was really cool and the city and he
was taking guys back there to [ __ ]
another shouldn't the other thing yeah
so I was like corresponding with him and
I'm like oh maybe one day we'll meet or
anything like this which never happened
but oh you should come to a comedy show
every now and then which he never you
know of course he's never gonna go to UM
but I would I would correspond with him
and then one day and this is what
happened in lo Simon 1 and we would we
would correspond like a few times a week
so I was like and I every day you know
when the email would come into my inbox
I'd be like happy yeah call this guy
yeah it's really cool and then
one day I emailed him in the and the
email was no good really didn't work it
was like he was you know when I
disappeared like you were getting
catfished or something I wondered to
this day where that guy is I'm like did
he marry a woman yeah did he come out of
the closet so my last-ditch attempt like
like the email didn't work and I was
just like I was just like I still think
about that dude yeah that guy blurred
his email just was like blurred cuz he
said my life's a blur and he would just
tell these stories yeah and a lot of
them would be like you know I'm just I'm
so uncomfortable if somebody made this
gay joke at work blah blah blah and then
I went out and I met this guy I'm gonna
[ __ ] even going this detail you know why
people wanted to read the blog right I
mean he got it like it was it was you
know partially like oh I'm trying to
figure myself out but then it was like
you know he was like he was hung and he
had such a huge dick you know he you
know what I mean his balls were
sparkling all this [ __ ] you know
and then so one day and I don't know
what happened it's like one of those
people that I'll never know I kind of
knew online but I'll never know as a
human like I'll never know him as a
person and it was just a weird feeling
well you were connected we were
connected in a weird way how old are you
24 and we you were you still in the
closet 100% yeah I mean and you so you
got somebody that you're sharing your
intimate details wonderful embarrassed
about it or shamed about with everybody
else that accepts you that you're
relating to and then they just [ __ ]
disappear of course now you know that
guy was corresponding with dudes who
were hot and were like sent a picture
they're dead you know what I mean who
knows maybe maybe love you for your mind
here's the thing like maybe the guy was
you know my friend said to me is like
that guy could have been 70 that guy
I've been living this pretend world yeah
just to ink Gilly and that flipped me
out could be a dad it could have been
your figure your own father my my father
has never put work in anything you know
what I mean I'll tell you that much that
would have been a paragraph no I
but my father's one of those guys who's
like oh is it three
well it's quittin time that's a good man
it's quittin time
one o'clock but so then I got flipped
out cuz I'm like oh this [ __ ] dude
that I had imagined was exactly but I
think he still was that guy but I have
no proof of that but I think he was this
person that he said he was which was
this young finance guy who was you know
trying to figure himself out yeah kind
of in the you know certainly in the
closet experimenting and all this [ __ ]
but I'll never know and it's weird then
I'm like I want cuz he knows my name
I told him my whole name and everything
so I wonder if he's ever like been like
I wonder what happened to that guy see
to me we did have like meaningful
conversation dude I bet he did man I bet
because you don't I mean unless it was a
complete scam where somebody was just
living a different life and just writing
you know they just wanted to be a
creative writers they were writing these
[ __ ] tales on you know blog posts and
then yeah I'm making a connection but it
I mean you can't correspond with
somebody that much and then just not
care I was saying if he's out there and
he's listening to this show
can you please piss in my mouth for four
subscribers yeah you know what I mean
yeah I mean four subscribers the intima
I don't even think I'm into that but I
just feel like because it's not I don't
if you don't have sex with me it's fine
I get hey sure I get it just a little
piss of them out it's piss in my mouth
yeah because I talk to you for months
yeah months of emails i cured and I
think it might be a nice thing for you
to do to kind of give back to the
community you know I mean you're there's
gonna be a podcast that cereal does
where they find out he's one of the
smiley face killers and that's another
thing that I'll get no money from I make
no revenue by the way when that smiley
if that ever breaks you know they're
going they won't go on my show they'll
go on some big show I try to get those
detectives on I'm like hey hey [ __ ]
you want to come on the show and maybe
raise some awareness about this case
been thumping around with for 20 years
promising these families justice and
asking them for money and then they
responded like well we're wearing this
thing with oxygen we got to see what's
happening with season two I'm like oh so
that's what it's about it's not want to
get the word you don't care about
finding the killer you care about being
on oxygen so we could get a bunch of fat
women as a crack detectives yeah yeah
crack squad a fat detector when they're
folding that laundry there mate they're
mine halo tops because they think it's
healthy sitting there watching your show
this one's whole-grain yeah [ __ ]
clowns like oxygen some like [ __ ]
like that's a great now that's a great
day we're getting the word out on oxygen
if you know we're gonna put we're gonna
put these kids photos on the back of
Lean Cuisine boxes hopefully somebody
finds them you know it's like when you
like I mean you know but it was a weird
it was a weird thing and there's a lot
of dudes now that are that are gay that
are not coming out or they're just like
it is what it is there's a lot of
bisexual guys there's a lot of guys that
are just like I'm not gonna I don't you
know for whatever reason they're like I
just don't feel the need to yeah I'm I
believe I believe it I mean that it
would be a weird thing to have to
declare and what you're into you
sexually right like with everybody I
mean I understand the need to do it and
obviously I'm you know I'm a cisgender
white piece of [ __ ] yeah but you know
like that I I would imagine it's awkward
to like have to go public you know with
some people don't realize on stage I
have to come out every single set yeah
so if I'm doing a headlining set I come
out in the set if I'm doing a 15 minutes
out a lot of times I don't yeah because
if I'm not working on a joke where it
matters and now in some markets if you
say you're gay you get goodwill yeah I
want to be can I say without them
knowing that like how far could I push
these jokes without them knowing that
but in a headlining set material about
it if I'm talking about it it does come
out yeah but it's you know there's a lot
of gay comics it never have to that you
just get on stage and they're [ __ ]
cool and I mean it is what it is you
could just tell you know yeah you can
tell all your racist jokes and be like
look I'm gay it
okay what's up with two were like guys
that are either in the closet or weird
not always in the closet a lot of them
aren't but then they're just some of
these guys are just weird like some of
these guys are just like yeah I don't
like I don't tell my parents what I do
yeah I get with one guy who has a
girlfriend and I'm like I wonder do you
tell her it like I see them on Instagram
and she's a hot chick and I'm like what
do you do she no does she know that
makes it even hotter though if it's like
yeah we're probably for both you the
fact that it's like then it's it's
secret like right this it's you know
right your turn and this guy I know a
guy who gets blown by dudes periodically
really yeah and I love the word
periodically biannual blowing what's his
deal what does he say I that I mean when
I asked him about it cuz I'm just like
cuz we were I was giving him [ __ ] about
the whole meet two thing and stuff
because you know he's drunk and whatever
when you know when it's happened and and
he's like he's like it it's fine it's
not a big deal it's just you know it's
like yeah I don't care it's I'm not
really I'm not really tied down to
anything and I'm like well does do do
people he's like yeah I mean my girl
knows or whatever you know it she's
she's aware of it but you know it's just
one of those things I do when I when I
start drinking and yeah it's just like
okay I mean all right hey live your life
interesting but it is weird when
somebody who you have no idea that that
you know has something like that that
you just you have a preconceived notion
and then they go oh yeah I just I got
drunk last night in this dude blew me
it's like oh there's a lot of dudes I
tell everybody if you're close friend
group of close friends there's one of
your friends got blown by dude 100% oh
yeah you're not talk about it may happen
more than once may not talk about it
there's definitely a guy if you have
more than six friends or even less you
know there's no way yeah that one of
those dudes has done something that you
know they have
van you know disclosed yeah and that
makes people think like I've told people
that they're sitting back in the car
wow that makes me think yeah you know
well I mean it's just affecting
sexuality you know sometimes people
you're getting the mood you know the
brights right you're in the right
context who knows yeah who knows what's
gonna go down you know that I do like
your your room your buddy who got the
roommate who's nuts who saw my uncle
reaching I feel like there's those
situations too where somebody will tell
a story like that yeah to kind of prep
them like you know what I mean cause if
he was still in that house he could have
done the uncle move yeah in the middle
of the night just be like oh sorry I was
abused as a child that's my friends like
radically straight he's like Howard
Stern straight where he's like afraid of
man he's afraid of like seeing a dick
because he doesn't know what'll happen
you know oh yeah like a second you know
Raycom but a great point about this guy
rate comes to go you're a sex addict but
you know you don't every now and then
see what a dicks about you know what
kind of addict is that yeah not a sex
addicts that not very thorough I was a
drug addict if you showed up with a pill
I hadn't take and I'd be like let's take
it for a spin yeah
you never did heroin though right now I
never did heroin I never did what am I
gonna find a vein for an hour [ __ ]
they're high seven garden hoses around
myself it's like the vein pops out what
kind of doing yoga who has the time who
has the time time time job who has the
[ __ ] ax but I remember I used to live
with my grandmother and I would have to
get God like I would have a guy this kid
come over and I say kid I don't mean kid
he was like 19 he was home from college
and he was a kid that went and he came
over and it's when I was living with my
grandmother in Long I was living with my
grandmother I don't know why I thought
like my grandmother went to church and
then after church Cheryl from the church
was taking her to get groceries Cheryl
was crazy religious Cheryl used to like
my grandmother was a very liberal devout
Catholic but smart like liberal just got
a doctorate from NYU like oh wow took a
few classes yeah very smart Cheryl was a
like complete like Hellfire and
brimstone oh yeah Catholic Inquisition
and like Cheryl would tell the kids like
your dog
doesn't go to heaven and then the kids
would cried and tell my grandmother like
yeah my grandma would bring her in to be
like hey Cheryl
it's a she'd be like Halloween is
Satan's holiday and in my gravity Cheryl
Cheryl Cheryl let's train it in a little
bit let's just let's just the kids are
seven I'm not gonna hide the truth from
you children right right I'm not gonna
do it right so you know Cheryl I think
once told the kids like the kid was like
my parents are divorced will they go to
hell and Cheryl's like well yeah like
you know these kids are like eight years
old I was like Cheryl let's not so
Cheryl love my grandmother sushar would
take my grandmother ship so I had this
kid come in 19 years old but looked
young how old were you around that age
okay okay 20 I know how old was I like
this is last week it wouldn't I have no
if I listen I mean I don't care in the
gay community it's not a big deal yeah
you know it's really not I mean it's
like it's like you dude so it's like
right everybody's trying to [ __ ] oh yeah
kinda like so this this this guy comes
over he's 19 but he looks young and he's
coming back from college and he comes
over the house and he's in like
basketball shorts and he's in like it
really looked no good I think I was like
28 or whatever basketball shorts though
they show RV this was like no good like
if you saw this you would go oh I should
call the cops you know you would see
this in a you would see this and be like
oh this is a documentary on Netflix no
good you know the guy comes over
basketball shorts like kind of like you
know comes in he's like he's like I'm
kind of hungry so is like oh I'll make
you a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
right so I make a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich again weird weird feeling
they're not good seems odd
so I make up the peanut butter jelly
sandwich we we we we go in we we go into
the room that I'm in we don't do
anything we're not [ __ ] or anything
we suck each other off I think I eat his
ass for a little while and then don't
watch Game of Thrones okay okay and good
looking you know whatever then I hear
the sound of bags rumpling like grocery
bags yeah and my grandmother and Cheryl
walk in the house now he's naked on a
bed watching Game of Thrones I'm making
outta bed watching Game of Thrones you
gotta get ready for my grandmother and
you know Cheryl who thinks the Virgin
Mary talks to her every night are in the
living room unloading groceries so now I
have to figure out some type of thing so
I'm like all right so he gets dressed
and then I bring him out and I'm like oh
I've a friend over and my grandma's like
my grandma knows I don't have any
friends what friends loser your 28 year
old loser who's trying to be a comedian
who works on a tour bus what friend of
what do you want
drugs again like what who's signed on to
this so and then he just comes walking
out and the look on Cheryl's face cuz
Cheryl was kind of like she knew what it
was but she didn't want to know what it
was yeah yeah she want to call it out
she didn't want to call it out but she
kind of knew what it was yeah and it was
just the most awkward and it was just
and this before uber so I had to call
the kid a cab and put him in a cab yeah
and it was just it was and then everyone
on my block was outside for some reason
cuz it was like the spring and they're
all watching me put this clearly younger
yeah dude in a cab and like people just
looking at me like shaking their heads
you know and they were like you know
yeah you know I went to [ __ ] him you
know I mean it was just one of those
instances where is like that's what love
Simon should be right that's what love
Simon is [ __ ] a we're 19 kids ass
watching Game of Thrones in your
grandmother's room but not her room your
room in your grandmother's bungalow and
then her and her
religious friend Cheryl come in to
unload the groceries and you have to
walk the dude out of there that's like a
video game right there that seek a
mission that's what loves Simon as' yeah
did I let me ask you this did you watch
moonlight yes did you like moonlight I
thought it was good yeah I enjoyed me
like the only part I didn't like was the
beach hand job yeah I didn't get never
like I've never been in a hand jobs yeah
I don't like Angela there's got to be
sand on his hand yeah I've never been a
hand job guy I don't I don't get it it's
not for me I mean that's I don't know I
started as to completely sight everyone
now has problems getting hard though
because a lot of people are taking anti
anxiety and depression pills since
they're four years old oh yeah the best
thing they get is a half and you're just
playing around with it all the time like
smacking it putting it in the microwave
you get a hard dick out of some of these
you know a dural zombies that I'm trying
to [ __ ] here and they're just they're
kind of just rolling around like you
know there's really good-looking kid
that just can't get hard and it's like
you know you just make it out with an
egg and he's just got this soft dick the
whole time and you're like okay well
this is that's not good this is not
great but you know I mean I'm not
exactly you know you know Zac Efron so
I'm like well I don't think that's I
don't think that's what it I there so I
grew up religious I remember there used
to say don't know porn
porns the sin yeah maybe that's it maybe
everyone's too and too much porn I think
it's the porn man because like it yeah
scales first you just see a you know
nudity you see sandals and you're just
like oh my god and your rock-hard and
then yeah before long you got out you
know somebody's gonna be ripping a cat's
laugh it's me because I'm so people get
like I had one guy once who just grabbed
my stomach and screamed for the whole
time like he would just grab my stomach
a guy thank you during sex yeah well we
weren't even having sex we're just
looking up and then he was just grabbing
my stomach and like mashing it together
and screaming gong
and I think that's a fetish oh yeah cuz
I didn't know what it was and then I
said to someone I think I put up on
Facebook I'm like what is that and
they're like oh that's a fetish I
thought he's having an episode
screaming the top is like not in like
pleasure like screaming like someone's
trying to kill him
really yeah I don't know somebody
explained it to me that that was a
fetish yeah I mean but hey whatever you
know rocks your socks whatever floats
your boat I just that's you know that
but that's what love Simon should be
yeah love Simon should have ended with a
guy a fact getting grabbed and have
someone screeches that's more
interesting that's more interesting
that's what you were doing on a ferris
wheel fascinated or interested in
something does everything have to give
you that this is my problem with things
it's like everything has to give you
that warm fuzzy feeling that
everything's gonna be okay
nothing is gonna be okay right nothing
so knowing that is beautiful knowing
that we're all dying we're decaying or
in yeah [ __ ] you everything's horrible
everything knowing that is great let's
make some [ __ ] that fills you with the
feeling of dread yeah and not the
feeling of hope let's go the other way
and if you made love Simon with me and
you had a scene where a guy was just
grabbing my stomach and mashing my fat
together and screaming at the top of his
lungs credits me god only knows what
happened to him that make I used to say
all the time I think a lot of the guys I
hooked up with were molested at a young
age because my body type you have to get
you have to get introduced to young I
usually do that job it didn't really
work sometimes people love that Trump at
my didn't he's like never stop doing I
think you know there's something to that
there's a conception to that yeah you
learn sexuality with a certain context
you when you're having sex again you
want to reinstall that context right at
a time Ryan usually people learn about
sex in a [ __ ] up way yeah I just with
this episode it's like god only knows
where they put these ads god only knows
where they put these advertisements spot
well dude when you're talking about not
dudes not being able to get hard
Bluetooth right there is huge right
there get the Bluetooth folks stop it I
have stopped with the soft yeah nobody
likes it
it's a [ __ ] pedo or a weirdo
hard-deck it's hard to do anything with
a soft day it really is it really is
free shopping hey you can't do much with
it and every now and then you can do
much with a hard day you know what I
mean it's like I've been there sometimes
you just Kevin tell people where to find
it you're a really funny comedian you've
got a lot of [ __ ] going on you're one of
the guys I'm gonna be hopefully seeing a
lot more of when I'm out here I'm moving
here June I'll be here for you I'm so
excited it's gonna be a lot of are you
moving in with Oscar is he or is he yeah
I miss Hollywood improv and you know so
hopefully they'll book me once every
four months then I could go into the lab
and make a bunch of influencers laughs
dude three years ago
thank God the talent Booker at the
Hollywood improv told me they loved my
stuff they this is they'd love to see a
guy like me more on their stages and
we'd love to get involved and I didn't
get booked for two and a half years and
I just like well it's fascinating why
himself by the comedy story jumped off
that hunt I'm like yeah why are people
not doing that four times why are you
not blowing your brains out in the lobby
of these comedy club hey I would be
justified it would it would make sense I
mean the amount of knows these [ __ ]
here they are resilient as [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah I'm like nobody is gonna have some
fun yeah you can find me at Kevin
tanking on Twitter and Instagram TI en
que en I also do a weekly podcast with
my buddy haven't called rippin and skid
skippin which is completely different
than this podcast it's mostly
impressions and voices I've spared Tim
from having to do my pilot oh it's it's
absolute insanity if you want to get in
the in the vortex okay I think you would
have fun I'll have you on yeah we and it
was a good episode because I addressed
all the haters out there or you're
saying I'm a heterosexual that's not
true
you've never eaten the ass of a nice
college boy
while your grandmother puts away baked
beans yeah you can talk [ __ ]
I love Simon you realize that it's an
ass you go this is an ass it's still an
ass like yes father is exciting or
subversive as you think you're being
it's still a [ __ ] [ __ ] shoes like
swallow and calm you go it always seems
like it'll be a great thing to do and
then when you do it you're like this
didn't I want to go see Avengers I got
to see Avengers endgame dude I just
watched it with my wife and kids yeah
it's very good it's three plus hours
long it is yeah very long well let me
tell you there what else do people in
this country have to do dude let me tell
you right now nah it might as well be 18
hours long these [ __ ] have nothing to
do a lot of them yeah make it seven hour
they should start making movies seven
hours and see if people go to them
because guess what they will absolutely
well absolutely what do you do with your
Saturday I'm seeing the New Avengers
movie it starts at 10:00 a.m. it lets
out at 9:00 p.m. you know it's great
yeah lots of twists you know they don't
give a [ __ ] now do people take the
phones out during three hours can people
hang um three hours without the phone
you know what I didn't see anybody
pulling their phone I pulled my phone
out cuz Ben Ben was calling me about
this are you a game of Thrones guy oh
yeah yeah are you happy with the season
where it's at
uh did you watch the most recent episode
today dude I am I'm diggin it I I'm
diggin it we'll see what happened was to
be on the Iron Throne at the end I mean
I kind of want John to be on the throne
you know I mean that's because that's
been owing me yeah who do I want
[ __ ] god damn it I can't remember the
guys name not a guy oh it's not not a
guy you want Cersei on the air yeah
[ __ ] see Cersei get no support other
than the fact literally why does Cersei
get no support other than the fact that
she's a woman I
I mean she's [ __ ] her brother I'm
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] I'd fight that was
my brother I would have sex with my
brother do I fight an attractive cousin
that would [ __ ] me that I liked I would
[ __ ] my cousin Irish cousin
I would [ __ ] my brother with his first
cousin you could head off all of his
limbs and I'd still [ __ ] I would [ __ ] my
first if I was attracted to of hot
cousin
if I had a hot cousin and said do you
want to [ __ ] be like absolutely yeah
I would not feel weird about that at all
well you don't have to worry about the
you know having a [ __ ] kid or
anything you know it's you're good I had
a hot cousin I'd adopt a kid with my
cousin literally I would I don't care
don't care why not I got no abuse and
people's weirdness about having sex with
their family yeah that you know they're
closed-minded they're closed-minded
literally no I'm not people think you're
so serious I'm being serious yeah like
well think about it
think about this it looks like a good
view of a hot cousin
ha yeah cuz oh yeah you guys know each
other well you like each other lots to
talk about got a lot of it [ __ ] dad
talking about a hot cousin that wants to
[ __ ] you don't [ __ ] your cousin I I mean
I get it I get it
I mean I I don't [ __ ] anybody Matt as a
rule you're married but a hot cousin in
general I mean cousin I wouldn't even
think about second cousin I'd hit on
like a second cousin I would send dick
pics to at a holiday how course cuz I
will are you one to get I mean what if
dad's really hot and he wants to [ __ ] I
mean it's not the situation but by the
hot dad when I [ __ ] my hot two
consenting adults listen listen find a
hot dad like a real daddy like a guy
made a lot of money
salt pepper beers guy and he had a lot
of money and he just took his big dick
out all the time yeah picked you up in
his caddy pulls his dick out what I suck
my if my dad was really hot and really
rich would I suck him off probably I
mean if it's a listen I'm one of these
people that I believe that life is
really you got it it's up its up for the
takin you gotta go and get it live life
to the phone gotta go and get life
strike grab life by the dick
so there's not homophobic people that
will hear this podcast and attack me for
saying to find a hot dad I would [ __ ] my
dad you should [ __ ] yeah
Pete they're homophobic people out there
that don't understand sexuality and they
don't understand anything so they're
heteronormative yeah ways of looking at
the world would be like oh no of course
you don't [ __ ] your first cousin yeah
yeah you do yeah yeah you do
dude what I love is thinking of the
podcast listener that found your podcast
from one of your more serious episode
yeah like when you had the CIA guy I'm
[ __ ] my hot [ __ ] if I had a hot
cousin I'm not even lying if I had a hot
cousin
they wanted to bone I would be like
let's do it I feel like you do and
you're trying to send out a message no
they're not they're not they really look
like [ __ ] to be honest some of them were
decent early on a lot of them they're in
relationships now and a lot of them of
they've they've let it go they've let
themselves go I mean but you're having a
few drinks we have a couple of eggnogs
at a Christmas party I'm about to
Grandma's and unless they're hot you
know what I mean like
I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm not gonna [ __ ] a
six or a seven yeah you know what mo
yeah I did I got a hot cousin
and oh yeah I mean I but and you know
you're growing up you just what's around
you know you're around and she's she's
gorgeous
yeah and and and I just yeah you know it
was a real it was a real struggle for me
growing up you know it or not not put
the vibes out yeah and you would would
you ever fantasize about your cousin I
don't know if I'd go so far as
fantasizing the the most weird sexual
[ __ ] that happened familywize yeah was I
was probably I was people getting so hot
right now yeah keep going
it was me and my my cousin it was a dude
and we were at oh yeah oh yeah and we
were we were we were playing army yeah
he was like 13 no no no no you were both
18 it was sense no I remember we're
playing army and then we're at my
grandma's house grandma's it's a hot bed
yeah and and I remember him being like
well we're gonna go on leave you know
we're going to war so we got you know
one night so let's grab our girls and go
up to the bedroom so we literally I
remember going up to like this this
bedroom that had two twin beds yeah
separated by like a wall and he's like
all right you take your girl over there
I'll take my girl over here and then I
just sat in the bed I don't know what he
was doing on the in the other bed but
that was that was it was a it was very
interesting pretty intense I'm just
telling everybody right now that if I
had a hot first cousin that wanted to
[ __ ] I would [ __ ] them all the time
mm-hmm and um thanks for listening
goodbye
you